para comenzar esta charla me gustaría
proponerles un ejercicio a ver si me
acompañan es un ejercicio muy sencillo y
lo voy a mostrar dos imágenes por siete
segundos y luego les voy a hacer un par
de preguntas vale
esta es la primera observe la por 7
segundos
bien ahora les voy a pedir que levanten
la mano aquellos que crean que esto
podría ser una persona exitosa
ahora les voy a pedir que levanten la
mano aquellos que crean que esto podría
ser una persona que fracase
esta otra imagen siete segundos mismo
ejercicio
bien ustedes creen que esta persona
podría ser una persona exitosa
y quien de ustedes cree que esta podría
ser una persona que fracase
siete segundos nos demoramos
neurocientífica mente hablando en
construir un sesgo y un estereotipo
respecto a alguien de estas dos personas
no sabemos nada no sabemos dos se han
estudiado no sabemos con qué no se
criaron no sabemos a qué se dedican
no sabemos qué sueñan y que aspiran no
sabemos nada sin embargo fuimos capaces
de dirimir en siete segundos quién
podría ser alguien exitoso y quién
podría ser alguien fracasado esto es
importante porque la forma en que vemos
depende de los clientes que nos ponemos
hoy día yo estoy para acá viendo de una
manera particular
no porque tengo unos lentes literales
sino porque efectivamente tengo un
background que puede ser muy distinto al
que tiene cualquiera de ustedes que está
sentado del otro lado y esto es
relevante porque como vemos define lo
que nosotros llamamos la realidad y para
ejemplificar esto les quiero contar una
anécdota hace un par de años yo estaba
en un desayuno con siete gerentes
generales de las empresas más grandes de
este país
y empresas que están convencidas de que
hay valor en la diversidad y gestionan
activamente este valor dentro de sus
organizaciones en este desayuno
estábamos con la ministra de la mujer y
la equidad de género hablando sobre
cuáles eran los principales problemas de
este país en temas de gente nos habló de
la brecha salarial nos habló de la
feminización de algunos trabajos nos
habló de cómo se distribuía el trabajo
doméstico como las labores de cuidado
estaban solo cargado la mano hacia las
mujeres etcétera habló habló habló
durante media hora sin interrupciones
cuando ella terminó su exposición se
dirige a estos siete hombres y les dice
alguna pregunta algún comentario algo
que les haya llamado la atención
y lo único que obtuvo fue silencio
brazos cruzados sobre el pecho cara de
póquer yo mi ingenuidad e dije bueno
quizás fue tan contundente la
presentación que está reflexionando
porque bueno son datos abrumadores ya yo
también estoy como un poco para adentro
súper
en esos cinco segundos eternos el
gerente general de la época de mi
organización comenzó a parafrasear a la
ministra para romper la atención bueno
lo que quiere decir la ministra cuando
se refiere a tal cifra o lo que se
refería yo creo que es súper importante
y hay uno de estos gerentes lo paró en
seco le dijo bueno ahí sí tiene sentido
porque si lo dices tú que eres un hombre
buen objetivo si lo hizo una mujer
pareciera que está sangrando por la
herida
todos quedamos perplejos pero sonó un
poco violento por decirle alguna manera
pero no fui capaz de decir nada ni yo ni
la ministra ni el gerente general de mi
organización de ese entonces ni ninguno
de los otros seis gerentes que estaba
sentado ahí ninguno dijo nada y sin
querer nos volvimos completas de ese
comentario
y luego nuestros respectivos trabajos
seguimos como si nada pasara pero algo
me quedo resonando y comencé a
reflexionar qué era lo que había pasado
ahí la conclusión a la que llegué es que
la discriminación está inserta nuestra
cultura entonces nadie dijo nada porque
tenemos están normalizados están
naturalizados es tan cotidiano que no lo
vemos y si lo vemos nos parece más
cómodo y más correcto no decir nada
no decir nada porque es conflictivo
y esto lo podemos ver en todo orden de
cosas hace un tiempo ya que vengo
analizando y hay una frase que me
encanta por su composición que es la
siguiente
les ha tocado verla y escucharla
blandito ustedes mismos
no tengo nada contra los olas pero
y esto parece políticamente correcto yo
alguna vez la ocupe y dije bueno estoy
diciendo super bien porque estoy
diciendo que no tengo nada en contra eso
ya una declaración super política pero
igual hay algo que me incomoda lo que
detrás de esta frase básicamente es que
no tengo nada contra los inserte aquí el
grupo el que usted quiere discriminar
pero inserte que su comentario es
terminado
metí esta misma composición para hacer
un experimento social en twitter en el
buscador y puso la frase textual no
tengo nada contra los y vi cómo se
completaba idea le traigo una magnífica
recopilación
no tengo nada en contra las personas con
discapacidad pero me molesta que no sean
agradecidos
no tengo nadie me va a obligar a
aprender creo o como se llame ellos
viven en chile o se adaptan a nuestras
costumbres o vayas a las duchas acaso
sobre amarillo no venía con un curso de
español no tengo nada contra los
migrantes que eso quede claro
no tengo nada contra los trans o
homosexuales que son minorías pero
legislar para ellos pasando por encima
de la mayoría no me parece
finalmente que está mi favorita no tengo
nada en contra de las mujeres
soy feminista pero el fútbol es un
deporte de hombres y no de mujeres para
eso está el juego con esos otros
deportes
si se dan cuenta estas frases son super
cotidianas yo en 5 minutos buscando en
twitter no me gusta nada llegar a este
tipo de composiciones
esto porque está inserto en nuestra
cultura y nosotros probablemente no nos
vamos a desgastar replicando está
diciendo y está haciendo discriminador
con esa frase sobre las mujeres
pero aquí es importante recalcar que no
estamos hablando de un problema de
minorías
como decía alguno de esos tweets no como
legislar para las minorías estamos
hablando de personas con discapacidad
personas migrantes personas de la
diversidad sexual personas jóvenes
personas mayores personas de regiones
personas pobres mujeres y cuando
hablamos de mujeres estamos hablando del
50 por ciento más 1 de la población
entonces deja de ser un problema de
minorías y es un problema de la sociedad
yo no sé qué tan familiarizados ustedes
están con él gender gap o el índice de
equidad de género que es una medición
que ocupa el word economic forum hace 10
años y mide a 144 países de todo el
mundo en distintas dimensiones
oportunidades económicas empoderamiento
político y asistencia a la educación
salud y bienestar
está el número 63 de 144 países
reguleque
lo bueno es que hemos venido creciendo o
mejorando nuestro ranking sostenidamente
en el tiempo si el 2016 estamos números
70 ahora estamos número 63 sin embargo
una de las cosas que mide este ranking o
este índice es en cuántos años vamos a
cerrar la brecha de género considerando
las cuatro dimensiones que les mencioné
el año 2016 se cerraba en 168 años
este año se cierran 217
por primera vez en los diez años de
medición del índice estamos
retrocediendo
y hoy estos datos me pregunte pero qué
es lo que pasa tenemos un movimiento
feminista histórico tenemos mucha más
conciencia estamos hablando de educación
no sexista estamos discutiendo respecto
al lenguaje inclusivo y estamos
retrocediendo
y lo hablé con una antropóloga de un
diplomado que estoy haciendo y le
pregunté a que creía que se atribuía
este tipo de retroceso
y ella me dijo mira camila no hay ni una
explicación lógica es una cuestión
cultural y el inconsciente todavía no
hemos presionado las teclas correctas
para que estar esta sesión
y ahí viene la invitación es que
efectivamente si nos demoramos 7
segundos en hacer un prejuicio respecto
a alguien esto se vuelve algo
inconsciente y tenemos en nuestra cabeza
nuestro mundo está construido por ese
tipo de sesgos cuando pensamos en un
hombre exitoso nos los imaginamos de una
manera cuando pensamos en una mujer
exitosa nos la imaginamos de otra manera
que no tienen ciertas características
lo importante para cerrar la brecha y
las otras brechas que tenemos como
sociedad es que hay que volver
consciente lo que es inconsciente yo soy
parte por asumir que nuestra forma de
ver no es la realidad
nuestra forma de ver es una construcción
es una construcción que está hecha por
nuestras experiencias y como es una
construcción se puede construir y esa es
la buena noticia entonces la invitación
que yo les quiero hacer que ustedes
hagan un ejercicio todas las mañanas
se levantan van en pijama medio
adormilado a lavarse los dientes y
tienen un espejo al frente no cuando
estén frente a ese espejo a lavándose
los dientes preguntan si quiero ser hoy
día
aliado aliada o cómplice
y esto es súper significativo puede
parecer fácil pero cuando uno elige a
ser aliado elige no dejar pasar nada
elige subir saludar y cuando el chófer
comienza a decir nos estamos llenando de
negros
uno tiene que hacer algo porque si no
sea algo es cómplice si no cuestiona es
el chofer en su visión sesgada te estás
convirtiendo en un cómplice si vas a un
carrete una fiesta y alguno de tus
amigos amigas comienza a decir oye si ya
no se puede decirle no se le puede decir
nada a la mujer todo es violencia
si ustedes no dicen nada se están
transformando en cómplices y esto no se
trata de convertirse la marga de la
fiesta como han dicho más de alguna vez
se trata
se trata de que las reglas y los
criterios para que la fiesta sea
divertida también muchas gracias
[Aplausos]